les habitants de Carson sont en liesse
ils ont accueilli un héros les soldats
vous le voyez craignent qui ont libéré
leur ville de l'armée russe
Jean-Philippe raconte
ils sont accueillis en héros portés par
les résidents de Kerson aujourd'hui
libéré les combattants immortalisent ce
point tournant dans la reconquête en
famille cet été
gloire aux forces armées ukrainiennes en
tonnes lessive rassemblées dans les rues
visiblement ému le drapeau jaune et bleu
flotte à nouveau sur la seule capitale
régionale ukrainienne tombée aux mains
de l'envahisseur
c'est une journée historique s'exclame
le président Zelinski nous regagnons le
sud du pays nous regagnons personne
mais alors que résonne ces crit
victorieux ce citoyen ordinaire retrouve
son chez soi qui porte désormais
l'empreinte de la dévastation russe
une destruction qui a emporté le
principal pont qui relie Carson et
l'arrive est de la rivière Denis père où
son maintenant repliés les troupes de
Vladimir Poutine radio
sont quittés la ville admel Kremlin qui
refuse toutefois de reconnaître le
retour de Kerson sous juridiction
ukrainienne le fait de se retirer du
côté S c'est vraiment un désaveu de leur
puissance c'est vraiment un échec un
retrait qui a toutes les apparences
d'une fuite désespérée comme en témoigne
les armes abandonnées ça ne peut pas
gagner cette guerre elle est en voie de
défaite c'est quelque chose qui est
inéluctable vu le désir de résistance
des Ukrainiens d'une part il veut le
soutien
occidental d'autres parents
cette nouvelle victoire militaire
galvanise les ukrainiens et fait naître
l'espoir d'une reconquête avant
l'arrivée de l'hiver ici Jean-Philippe
Radio-Canada Montréal